if it's worth doing it's worth doing
well I shortcuted so much stuff when I
was younger I just wanted to like get it
done get it done get it done rather than
doing it well there's kind of two ways
you can take the setting which is why I
like it so much many times I was doing
things that were not worth doing and so
I didn't have the time to do things well
because I was doing so many things that
were not worth doing because if it is
worth doing then I have to understand
that to do it comma right to do it well
it's going to take this much time now
given that is it still worth doing and
if it passes that test of a being worth
doing in the Long Haul and because it is
worth doing worth doing well then it
gives us this lens through which to see
the activities we do so that we can
prioritize the things that will make us
the most money or get us closer to the
goals we have